Hi.
My name is Allan.
I'm from Sao Paulo, and
I co-founded Kekanto.
Kekanto is a local social guide
where people can find
about places, write a review
about it, and find
recommendations, get offers,
see where their friends are
through check-ins.
And we are based in Sao Paulo,
but we are also available in
Latin America, in Buenos Aires,
Chile, and Mexico.
And I'm going to show a quick
demo of our website.
So this is the main
page of Kekanto.
I'm going to search
for churrascaria--
that means barbecue.
So I'll go to the top of the
page on the search bar, type
churrascaria in Sao Paulo,
and press Enter.
Then you've got all
results of all
churrascarias on Sao Paulo.
On the left, you've got all
of the churrascarias.
You can see where they are
on the map on the right.
You can also add filters like
prices, if you want to go with
your girlfriend, if you want
to go with friends.
And once you find a place that
you want, you can click here
on the place, and you've got all
the information about the
churrascaria.
You can get the address, the
phone number, the open hours.
You can get some pictures of all
the places, write a review
and read some reviews that other
people write about it.
And once you find a place that
you want, you can go to this
tab here, add your address.
For example, we are at Avenida
Paulista, Sao Paulo.
And then you click here,
and you've got the
directions to the place.
You can also click on this tab
here and see the Street View
about this place.
So this was a quick tip
about our website.
If you want to go, just type in
kekanto.com on your website.
And thanks for watching.
What I like about Google Maps is
the customization and a lot
of documentation.